[Music]
[Applause]
for much of the past century
america saw itself as the leader of the
free world
but its reputation in many rich
countries has reached a 20-year low
hardly surprising perhaps
the storming of the capital by pro-trump
supporters
marks the culmination of four years in
which the democratic norms of america
have been undermined and division has
reigned
incited by the only president to have
been impeached twice
there was a sense that america was a
beacon of democracy for the rest of the
world
and that has dissipated this is not
american
terribly distressing
the challenge facing joe biden's
administration is immense
how can he repair america's tarnished
reputation
and restore its role as a global leader
of all the democratic norms president
trump violated
during his four years in the white house
none was as damaging to america's
reputation
as his refusal to transfer power
peacefully
we will never give up we will never
concede it doesn't happen you don't
concede when there's
death involved an american president the
reported leader of the free world
uh using every means at his disposal to
try and counter man the result of an
election that he lost including
inciting a mob to go and ransack the
capital
that's going to be an indelible image of
the trump era
and one that america will always have to
confront in the future
when it tries to reassert its role as a
sort of global beacon for democracy
there's a very real sense among joe
biden's foreign policy team
that foreign policy begins at home and
that you have to
address america's own domestic problems
in order to be strong in order to be
admired
abroad including of course the great
challenge of
covert 19. in early 2020
as the covert 19 pandemic spread the
world looked to america for leadership
but instead of taking on that role
president trump retreated
dismissing the seriousness of the virus
it's going to disappear one day it's
like a miracle it will disappear
on the day that a mob stormed the
capital
nearly 4 000 americans died from covet
19.
more than 350 000 americans have already
died
it hurt america's global standing that
it was incapable of containing
the spread of covet 19. in july
trump formally announced america was
pulling out of the world health
organization
as president joe biden has said he will
reverse that decision
domestically he plans to hire 000
contact tracers and spend 25 billion
dollars on vaccine manufacturing and
distribution
and globally america is expected to join
kovacs
the international vaccine alliance to
deliver vaccines
not just in america but all around the
world
it's an international health crisis and
the idea
we're at war the virus and it is we're
at war
for real an engaged america can make an
awful lot of difference
it's important for the biggest crisis
that the world is facing it's also i
think an opportunity
for biden to really show in practical
terms that america is indeed back
trump not only withdrew america from the
wh show
but also from 12 other international
organizations and treaties
including the trans-pacific partnership
or tpp
we're going to stand up to china
withdraw from tpp which is another
disaster
reversing many of these decisions and
reaffirming america's commitment to
multilateral agencies
will be a relatively easy win for biden
he's going to leverage
the many relationships that he's built
over his nearly half century in
washington
to try and repair whatever damage has
been done
to alliances such as nato repair trust
in the multilateral institutions
such as the who to try and rejoin some
international courts on climate change
such as the paris accord
but in addition to the policy decisions
that he makes the rhetorical
shift that comes from the white house
which is so important
is is going to be i think the biggest
component of the change
america is going to be a rather more
predictable power than it was
under donald trump you're not going to
have the kind of sudden tweets that
reverse
carefully formed policies he won't take
the world by surprise
quite as much as donald trump did and
that in itself i think
is going to reassure america's allies
that america is more dependable than it
was before
america is back ready to lead the world
not retreat from it biden has announced
he plans to hold a global
summit of democracies which would bring
together democratic leaders
to discuss ways of pushing back on
autocracies
he will also want to find ways to
cooperate with the countries that are
rivals of america donald trump of course
introduced a policy of america first
he started a number of trade wars he
introduced lots of sanctions
most notably president trump imposed
billions of dollars of tariffs on
chinese products sold in america
well i'm very happy with china right now
that penguins billions and billions will
be over a hundred million dollars
in the not too distant future i think
donald trump has
recognized that china represents a deep
and
growing challenge to american power
biden is going to also take a tougher
stance on china than
previous administrations democratic and
republican because
both parties have lost faith that under
xi jinping
the chinese regime will at all
liberalize
biden will prosecute that campaign
with more certainty and less impulse
but the underlying reality of tariffs on
chinese goods
might remain for some time at the very
least they constitute some leverage
for you know future negotiations
that leverage may be useful when it
comes to global warming
particularly as china and america are
the world's biggest emitters of
greenhouse gases
and it's on climate change that biden
has the opportunity to reaffirm
america's world standing president trump
pulling out of the paris accord
ceded america's global leadership on
climate change
it'll start getting cooler i would just
you just watch
i wish science agreed with you oh well
i don't think science knows actually
president trump also dismantled
many of america's regulations that were
aimed at reducing carbon emissions
the biden administration is going to
reverse the reversals that donald trump
put into
place we'll bring america back
back into the paris agreement and put us
back in the business of leading the
world on climate change again
he has an ambitious uh domestic climate
agenda as well
this includes setting the target for
america of reaching net
zero by 2050 modelers say this target
will shave 0.1 degrees celsius of their
temperature projections
for the end of the century if biden can
formally submit this target
before the cop 26 u.n climate summit in
november
it will help convince other governments
that america plans to pull its weight
and then there's russia
biden's first challenge will be
extending the last remaining nuclear
arms control treaty
between the two countries which is due
to expire in early february
it's particularly important for the
maintenance of trust
between those two nuclear superpowers
it's by no means perfect it doesn't take
into account
other nuclear powers particularly the
rising power of china
but if it doesn't exist that would be
hugely problematic
with one eye on the treaty with russia
biden will also be looking to another
nuclear deal
one that is central to stability in the
middle east the iran
nuclear deal from which trump withdrew
in 2018.
i think joe biden would like to get back
into the iran deal but
the world has changed since president
trump left that deal so iran has
ramped up its nuclear activities so
just getting back to where things were
before is not going to be easy
one thing you have to remember is that
on iran america
will not be acting alone the original
iran deal was with
european powers and russia and china
that's a test if you like of the biden
administration's ability to work
across some quite difficult sets of
relationships
towards achieving a result many of
president trump's america first policies
were carried out by executive order
without the need of approval from
congress
which means they can be rolled back
using the same process
but only certain changes can be made by
executive orders
in order for biden to make long-term
shifts getting legislation through
congress will be key
and that will be much more difficult the
fact that democrats will
control over the senate and have
unanimous control over the levers of
power
in washington albeit by the slimmest
margins possible
suggests that he may be able to
accomplish a few of those far-reaching
things
but certainly not all of them and the
long-lasting
things that actually cement a
president's place in american history
will come
through a lot of hard and difficult
negotiations with congress
despite biden's ambitious plans
convincing the world america has shaken
off trump's legacy
will be an uphill battle
there's a tremendous desire to see
america back among
america's allies so that will be hugely
welcome but there's also
a suspicion on a number of levels
there's a suspicion first of all that
well if you could elect
someone like donald trump once it could
happen again
that's not something you can change over
life
if the senate convicts donald trump of
inciting an insurrection
it will go some way to signaling to the
rest of the world
that america's checks and balances do
work
but biden inherits a poisoned legacy if
he fails to heal a divided nation
and restore trust in its democracy then
these images could continue to challenge
america's role as leader of the free
world
for years to come i'm john prado the
economist's u.s
editor you can read all our coverage on
the inauguration and what's in store for
the biden presidency on the link
opposite
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
thank you for watching
you